did you ever see a lassie a lassie A
lassie did you ever see a lassie go this
way
Theo Theo when Theo was born I couldn't
even hold
him okay I was afraid I was going to
drop
him I'm a terrible mother you're a
wonderful
mother and a wonderful
friend I just want you to be happy too m
Max Max get down it's not safe
Max
help
[Music]
did y Max is
gone it wasn't easy bringing you into
this world now you've left her too
soon go this way you need to separate
the grief from the guilt what killed
Alice something's broken inside of me
and I need
you I saw the look in her eyes she
thinks that I should a saved person is
that coming from her or you you think
I'm imagining
things we're not going down this path
again you're
right God knows I can get carried away
sometimes
[Music]
can the come over for a little bit it's
amazing how quickly you forgot my son
our
son it helps me to spend time with Theo
but it helps him too do you miss
him selene's my friend get off the
balcony P wrong did you did you put Theo
on that balcony to test me do you think
I'm capable of
that she wants us to pay for Max
you're just accusing me of being some
kind of monster you're losing touch with
reality leave my family
alone I'm not imagining
things